and when you i get a lot of questions
specifically with people asking me
when will the great reset happen i'm
like it's here it's here
it's happening right now in front of our
very eyes and no one's even paying
attention and realizing
that it's the largest transfer of wealth
is happening right in front of their
eyes
john kerry came out he has a big
position inside of
the biden administration he came out and
said of course the biden administration
is going to go along with the great
reset we're going to implement it
quicker and faster than anyone could
even imagine
but yes people forget we're here we're
at this juncture right now the great
reset people this is you know klaus
schwab and the whole davos crowd the
world economic forum
one of their key catchphrases they've
been marketing for years is build back
better
build back better build all across
europe and they had it recently we saw
trudeau out of canada
and boris johnson and and uh you've got
biden talking about it but the funny
thing is if you go to the biden harris
transition website it doesn't say
bidenharris transition.gov
their website is literally
buildbackbetter.gov that is their
transition the talking points
website so this that's what these
european leaders that's their slogan
why is there a dot gov that's a slogan
of european leaders why is it the
the president-elects website build back
better what does that even mean
first off it's it's sort of a just
grammatically it's kind of a disaster
but
[Laughter]
is it like once once it falls apart
we're going to make it stronger again so
like if an animal is suffering you want
to put it out of its misery is that what
they're trying to do right now is
is put the system out of its misery so
they can come back stronger
everything's being destroyed and they're
going to build
back better but better there you go yeah
they're better they're just
i needed redefine
capitalism to make everything more equal
and more fair for everyone
and green you know the big powerful
globalists that are
responsible for so many ills and wrongs
in the world are now going to have a 180
degree flip
in their soul and actually start doing
good things for everyone just like they
promised in this very vague open
language that we hear
on the on the imf the world bank so i
just want the world economic forum
i do want to make sure we we cite all
this we have the hill john kerry reveals
biden's devotion to radical gree
uh great reset movement now to to be to
clarify this is from a contributor
justin haskins
but he does going to talk about the
great reset movement covid
and here we have the world economic
forum's the great reset website
saying there's an urgent need for global
stakeholders to cooperate in
simultaneously managing the direct
consequences of the covet-19 crisis
to improve the state of the world the
world economic forum is starting the
great reset initiative
we had on uh destiny are you familiar
with destiny
he's a a leftist uh although the
progressive
i guess the the woke left really hates
him because he said i guess he said that
kyle written out was defending himself
and so they went after him but he's
pretty lefty
he said he said isn't uh a crisis like
covid the perfect time
to do reforms to make the world a better
place isn't doesn't that make sense
so so uh i think the issue is
uh put a pin in that now i'll mention i
had alex jones on the show and i asked
him what if what if they're right that
you know humanity is hurtling towards
non-existence extinction because we're
destroying this planet stripping
resources and just burning ourselves
alive
don't we need to do something isn't it
is that possible and alex actually said
you're right i think about that all the
time
maybe but you know this is a very
serious challenge
and then ultimately what it comes down
to hearing this from say destiny or
hearing what alex thought about it
it's a question of your right to impose
what you think is right for the rest of
the world
and here's where the real real problem
comes in if you came to me and told me
tim the world is on fire and it's going
to end soon
i'd be like that's a problem what can we
do to solve it if i trust you
what if you're not right what if you
were just another crazy
person like all the rest of the crazy
people who thinks they know what the
world needs
you've got fascists who think they know
they know what the world needs i
certainly don't trust them
you've got communists who think they
know what the world needs i don't trust
them either
so if someone comes to me and says we
must impose authoritarian rule over
all of the people of the world to make
sure we survive i don't have any good
reason to trust what you're saying
i want the world to survive i want to
mitigate these problems i personally
think we got a problem with climate
change and you even mentioned
we've got we got a problem with
resources but who do i trust
who do we empower to put the boot down
over everybody else
so i a doctor once told me i love the
saying
people don't sue outcomes they sue
relationships so here's my relationship
with these elites at this point in time
they just lie about everything so
i'm actually fairly sympathetic to this
line of thinking if they said listen
we're 7.8 billion people normal
trajectory we're going to nine maybe 10
billion that's a fact
that's gonna happen by 2050. here's
where we are in the resource story
here's how much oil we think we have
left here's how much fresh water we
think we have left
there's a there's a gap here we have a
problem on our hands but let's pull
through this together so this would have
been like going to the nation
back in 1940 and saying we have to
defeat nazis right
and as long as you're honest about that
people will go okay you know if if
people know what the vision is they will
crawl through mud
literally you ever seen those people do
those mudders right like just crawling
like because they have tough mudder yeah
and it's team based and they want to do
it so people do amazing i have great
faith in people but i think what you're
talking about is that
the people who are pulling the strings
up there right now they don't have that
same faith in fact they
actually don't trust us so that means
we're in a relationship that's not based
on trust and so your question is a good
one which is why should i do anything if
i don't
trust you well well here's here's an
interesting conundrum i suppose you've
got the what is the ipcc
you know a consensus among scientists
climate change is happening
how do you feel about what's your
thoughts on climate change it's very
complicated
i've put not enough time into it to
really understand what's going on but
i get the basic theory of it and i don't
want to get into the actual politics
that that arises around it but i just
wanted to point out
that you've got a large faction people
who don't believe it's real
if you get someone like al gore coming
out the documentary and doing a
presentation saying you know here's
what's happening
and half the country believes it half
doesn't then i i don't necessarily agree
that if they came out and said here's
our plan people would just agree to do
it i think a lot of people would just
say no you can't tell me what to do but
it's not necessarily
around the climate change this resource
story is more direct more linear so
ocean acidification is something i
believe in completely because it's very
simple you take the partial pressure of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
and the higher it is the more there is
the more goes in the water the more
acidic it becomes period
and i know i've talked to oyster farmers
who can't grow oysters in both maine
and in in uh in this puget sound
because the ocean's too acidic but the
jellyfish comes in
people are eating the jellyfish now i've
never tried it it's good have you looked
into
iron fertilization yeah this whole idea
that we're going to geo engineer our way
out of this i think is
here's complexity theory is the most
important thing i've ever learned
and in complexity theory there's a
couple things like even if we had a
computer and we're modeling
sand being dropped when exactly when and
how much is that pile is going to slump
we don't know we can't predict it
we don't that defies us so when you say
do i believe in climate change it's not
a question of belief what i'll tell you
is it's not just a complex system
it's hundreds of nested complex systems
our ability to predict that
is zero right but we can sort of look at
the larger trends
which i do believe in but anybody who
has certainty about where anything's
gonna go or how it's gonna play out
i don't know about that side of things
but ocean acidification is dead simple
tell me how much how much co2 is in the
atmosphere and i'll tell you what's
going to happen
and so i've i've worked for
environmental non-profits and
we like we talk a great deal about the
dead zones that have appeared
and say like the gulf are you familiar
with these yeah from all the nutrient
runoff yeah
yeah so and there's also the other
problem uh uh
you mentioned freshwater i did a mini a
short segment
on a desalination uh desalination plant
in
i believe it was carlsbad california and
a lot of people are saying oh you look
we
the whole world is water we just got to
get the salt out of it we can drink it
what they don't realize is first of all
that creates
a mass movement of the water into other
areas but the brine
runoff from the when they pull the the
the brine
they basically takes hot water and they
pull out a bunch of you know water
molecules which gives them fresh water
they get a really dense salty brine
which then rolls down the bottom of the
of
of the ocean bed killing off all of the
smaller life forms creating this wave
that goes all the way up creating a dead
zone
where now there's nothing alive anymore
so that desalination is not a solution
to this
so that ul ultimately what i'm getting
to is
it seems like we can't just keep doing
what we're doing
can we nope that's the point so then we
just can't well so then so but
where's where's the balance between an
individual's right to choose and live
their lives for themselves and
huma like shaking humanity by the
shoulders and saying like you are
burning things to the ground what do we
do yeah but but the people who are
saying the
things are burning down they're lying
through their teeth and usually they are
connected to individuals who are doing
the burning
so when we look at the actual pollution
when we look at the actual issues that
the earth is facing
whether with natural resources or not or
or some of the studies that manipulate
the data to
to highlight that maybe it is declining
maybe it's not declining
a lot of this is contrived by
organizations that benefit from
this that get more power and control by
you believing
some some of these things and then they
extort it to get
power taxes they they wanted to do a
carbon tax on individuals
cnn again lambasted individuals for for
eating meat
and they're saying because of climate
change you're going to have to eat less
meat meanwhile they're not even talking
about the multinational corporations
that are mostly responsible
for the the carbon emissions that are
going on there and they're shifting the
blame on the individuals
when they're the ones creating the
problem that they magically have a
solution to that we have to go along
with
that's crazy i think a really good
question that needs to be answered is
when you look at greta tunberg she
complains about
the us and europe and she ignores china
and india
why is that if i'm if look i'm i'm here
with you man i'm ready to
to fight for the environment and all
that good stuff but i got a real i got a
real
problem with the ign when we ignore
a couple a couple very important
questions we ignore china
and india and they're pumping out tons
of carbon and i don't think graduate
complaint about that
the u.s is actually working hard to
reduce carbon emissions
find other ways to produce energy not
like it's perfect but then you also see
these these elites
who fly on jumbo jets and have big
houses but more importantly
buy beachfront property yeah like bill
gates bill gates recently bought beat
beachfront property haven't all of them
bought properties
but this is the thing we also have to
understand a lot of china's pollution
was predominantly responsible because of
other countries
sending their garbage to them and they
said that they're going to recycle it
they didn't recycle it
they sent it into the oceans and then
the world found out that cycling and
recycling mainly
in part was a large scam on the on the
people i think i figured it out
i think if you're dead you see all these
rich people buy this beachfront property
right
because they really want to live on the
beach barack obama just did it yeah
recently
but but then they're sitting there
thinking like i just invested you know
10 million dollars in this in this condo
right
and it's going to be under water in 20
years so they go to their body say how
do we stop my condo from going
underwater i know
let's lock everybody down so that no one
can do anything
because then they know we'll save
resources that means the the elites
i'm half joking by the way well there's
climate change
zealots right now that are coming out in
mainstream media publications and
they're writing editorials how we need
to continue these lockdowns we need to
prevent people from
riding cars we need to prevent people
from traveling
to stop climate change after we defeat
the coronavirus
we still have to continue these
practices because they're good for the
environment
meanwhile they point to the
responsibility at the individual
rather than the actual corporates the
culprits who are responsible for it and
it's absolutely sickening
and it's totally disingenuous quote
journalism it's pr propaganda for the
very rich to become richer
they they they they write that the
great reset is a conspiracy theory that
people think the elites are just locking
us down because of climate change and
not really because of coven
i got an article here from the world
economic forum themselves emissions fell
during lockdown let's keep it that way
yep well there you go think well they're
saying it
so if somebody says they're going to do
something and then it happens it's now a
conspiracy theory to suggest that that
might have been what happened well
that's what the new york times even
wrote they said if you talk about the
the great reset your conspiracy theorist
it doesn't exist it's not here meanwhile
other
other publications are like celebrating
it and saying that this is going to be a
great enemy
it started out with you you had you had
the world economic forum writing the
great reset here's what we're going to
do
then when the right conservatives and
libertarians started talking about it
the new york times said oh it's a
conspiracy it's not real
then about a week later you you started
getting these these mainstream
publications
just defending the great reset saying
far right
you know white supremacists etc are
attacking the noble and great reset
like we we are all working together for
a better world and these far
right white nationalists are harambe say
yeah but here's the thing that's that's
the trajectory things go through
you could ask uh every one of those
journalists and say what
exactly does the great reset entail and
what impact is it going to have on your
lives nobody knows
nobody has any idea about this right
except you don't drive your car i'm not
going to own anything i'm going to be
happy about that i'm going to rent
everything
have no privacy no privacy that's all i
know about it so far
that's you not them i think
there's gonna there's going what i think
i see happening right now is
there uh for a long time in the united
states upward mobility was a thing
the american dream existed for people uh
even people who didn't
who were not from here could emigrate
become american
find their american dream you could be
in poverty in the old country come here
work really really hard and eventually
your kids are living better than you've
ever dreamed and you've got your own
house and you've got to represent that
ponzi scheme to the top well so what's
happening now is
the american dream was upward mobility
you know in some countries
there's none because it's class based or
cast based well what's happening now is
with the great reset i think what
they're going to do is there's a hundred
ladders that you can climb for that
upward
upper upward mobility 99 of them are
getting the axe right now
and they'll keep one or two some people
will be allowed if they approve of you
and you you help them
and they will get to continue flying
around on jets running the world
doing whatever they want but hey look
emissions are down the world economic
forum says
let's keep it there i don't think that's
good does that does that mean they won't
be flying no it means you won't be
flying exactly
that's that's a great point that you're
making there and when you look at upward
mobility it's virtually almost
coming to a point where it's impossible
in the united states you look at
low-skill labor that's being replaced
with immigration
you look at high school labor with with
programming there's a whole bunch of
visa programs that are outsourced to
india and china that are literally
shipping in labor into the united states
so people going to college right now
getting into debt for the rest of their
life come out and there's there's no job
prospects out there and there's going to
be less and less of them
we were already facing a large economic
turmoil
especially in the retail market before
the coronavirus
now there's going to be a huge reckoning
and a huge restructuring
the great reset it's here it's the
largest transfer of
wealth and the they are they're
enforcing it with brute force if your
business
if if you don't if you don't transfer
your wealth to amazon to walmart to
target
the police will come after you they'll
shut you down the irs will audit you
and they will make sure any semblance of
self-responsibility any semblance of you
being able to fend for yourself
is eliminated and that's exactly what's
happening right now and it's sickening
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you